[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
coach I went speed trick-or-treating
today and trick-or-treating did you an
adult male all by himself
trick-or-treating huh
don't judge me judge my candy brown
allele and browns they all live in the
same house right
I got an almond joy makes sense for the
Browns right it's supposed to be good
they give you something disappointing
Eli Manning gave me these cookies you
made those yeah he had time cuz he's not
working behind his ol line anymore by
the way
loose cookies Brady's house you got to
dimension I got the code the exfoliating
scrub got the Kiwi any ideas yeah you
don't know and then more stem cells stem
cells again again so you go anywhere
else I got a package from Jon Gruden so
it came with the Raiders advisor
obviously this hair we got the the
Raiders shirt mm-hmm Oh overalls right
altogether what do you got all of
Chuckie Gruden right Chuckie Gruden
Halloween costume what are you gonna do
with that
I think obviously we should host a
Halloween special of your fantasy fire
drill
[Music]
why from the sports book at Caesar's
Palace in Fabulous Las Vegas it's your
fantasy fire drill and here's your host
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
your fantasy fires lob mad camp but I am
not dressed up for Halloween at all
alright maybe a little bit coach Gruden
made it to Vegas just a little bit early
well you can join me every single Sunday
right here on all bleacher report
platforms 11:30 Eastern 8:30 Pacific for
your fantasy fire drill what do we do
well we give you the injuries and
actives we'll cover those and there's a
bunch we'll talk about that I'll give
you my sleepers for the week can we stay
hot there we'll try to do so and I'll
get plenty of your questions in from all
the platforms but YouTube I see you get
your own section again today so make
sure you get your questions in and when
the show is done there will be plenty
more questions you will have and I will
get to them on the app I'll jump in
there for 30 minutes so without further
ado let's get this very special
Halloween edition of this program
started right now we'll do some trick or
treat later on but first what are the
tricks and treats of the inactives we
start right now with what we're looking
at for the early games there's multiple
pages of this Jack Doyle it's still up
in the air for this week I'll tell you
right now though I would favor Eric
Ebron more I'm not looking at Jack Doyle
but if he plays maybe it drops down
Ebron a little bit Oh J Howard the
nightmare that you have been dealing
with for the entire season is out today
should you look at Cameron great I am
not too high in him he's playing the
Titans it's a tough matchup but you
don't have to deal with OJ Howard today
he is out Delanie Walker for the Titans
is out today now we're gonna get to my
sleepers but if you read my sleepers
article on Friday
Johnny Smith was on there he's got the
Buccaneers one of the best matchups you
can have get Johnny Smith in there as a
deep sleeper a tight end Ava Johnson is
out today that's not a bad thing because
now we don't want to deal with last week
we don't have to deal with the one touch
it's all about chase Edmunds who could
be a top 15 back again today tougher
matchup though against the Saints
Christian Kirk is back this week but I
would say lower in wide receiver 3 as
he's still working his way back Drew
Brees is back this week and thank
goodness for that now the Saints have
been fine in terms of their standings
without Drew Brees but he's back today
and what does that do
we're getting information on chimera
and Jared cook if Jared Cook is
definitely out and he is out we can tell
you that now with Drew Brees playing I
do have more confidence saying you can
take a deep sleeper shot on Josh
Hill was coming off his best game of the
season dd Westbrook has been playing
pretty solidly while waiting for
official word on his status he's been a
pretty nice wide receiver three what
some upside has the Jets Kris Herndon
for the Jets is out now I would still
stash them because we're not deep a
tight end at all
while we're talking about Johnny Smith
and Josh Hill but no Kris Herndon again
for this week more early game inactives
and we'll start with sterling Shepherd
he remains out I still think he's
somebody you want to keep around but I
will tell you this golden Tate's a
pretty good play today so sterling
Shepherd is out Keenan Allen though is
in now he was a game-time decision went
through warm-ups this morning is he a
hundred percent certainly not but I'm
not sitting down Keenan Allen at any
time you're gonna play him today
hopefully gets through doesn't make any
make things too much worse Matt Ryan is
out today it's a one win team not
something the Falcons should mess with I
have gotten three júlio questions the
answer is yes you're still playing Julio
Jones Matt's job is not some random
rookie he's not Matt Ryan I get that now
do you have a second thought about
Ridley yeah sure I get that but you're
still playing Austin Hooper with
confidence as well those are your early
game and actives well update what we
need to later on in the show
here's we have later on today and
tonight Josh Jacobs and Tyrell Tyrell
Williams are both expected to play
Jacobs is a solid RB 2 you know that
already
Tyrell Williams has banged up for a
couple of weeks I do have Derek Carr as
a sleeper this week and part of that's
because Tyrell Williams should be back
and they're playing a very beatable text
in secondary they give up big plays that
could be a very sneaky good fantasy game
a lot of points on the board because
there's not a lot of defense Bill
Belichick's board so he just writes
Julian Edelman 'he's named on the injury
report every week he'll be fine
patrocle holmes is out it's not a bad
thing i know this you're going wait what
do you mean it's not a bad thing do you
really want him playing at far less than
100 percent you don't maybe they lose
tonight against the Packers by the way
Demonte Adams very much up in the air
probably not back this week but get
rather mahomes take a little bit more
time so you're not putting them out
there and then watching a player who's
far less than 100% struggle at time so
well up
those early game inactives a little bit
later on in the show but now we get to
your first run twice that's what the
show is all about what do you have for
me for week eight okay man choose one
for flex John Brown Tyler boy tide
Johnson will talk about tide John it's a
little bit but I love John Brown one of
my guys gets the Eagles secondary a very
beatable matchup at home for the Buffalo
Bills today when Chris Herndon comes
back will he be a must our tight end
from crazy north I'm not saying must
start because we got to see it happen
but he's certainly worth stashing
because he is a talented player
especially if they Trey and Robbie
Anderson that couple of days
Josh Allen where Kyle emerge from Z dot
Josh Allen's a top-five quarterback this
week against that beatable eagle defense
and as always look for legs he can run
next up here should I pick up Devante
Parker Robbie Anderson from waivers dat
you never pick up Devante Parker unless
you want to lose next one here
moving on NRC picking up Arnold for next
week so they dropped Henderson or Samuel
I would drop sandal we're gonna get into
Todd Gurley and the Rams backfield
coming up I want to keep Henderson
around it could be a league winner in
the second half of the season
Coleman sharp or taped for Flex good
spot there Bruce I'm not sitting shark
he's playing at a real high level and
he's got the Jets let's go to the wall
we have a viewer question hey guys I've
got a tough flex decision this week that
I need your help with
should I play Corey Davis first Tampa
Bay Mike Williams very cago or Mohamed
Sanu
new to the Patriots versus Cleveland
which one's the best choice this week go
bills a happy bills fan late in the
season this late in the season you love
to see it I'm gonna tell you this
because Keenan Allen's playing to nail
shy away from Mike Williams I'm gonna
take a shot on sinew you don't have Josh
Gordon out there Browns have been a mess
I'll take a shot on to new we're just
not fully confident in one player in the
Titans offense just yet and don't worry
we'll be talking more about that coming
up in fact
[Music]
[Applause]
coach it's great to see you you've been
going through a lot of speed rounds in
the last week oh it's me it's coach I'm
coaching coach I'm a Maddie what have I
taught you this conversations moving too
slow right come on tell me who's a trick
and who's a treat okay thanks coach
still says bye notice that I wonder who
could that be
now trick or treat it's a Halloween show
we are obligated to do a Halloween
segment so let's make it fantasy it's
Halloween but naked fantasy I've heard
that somewhere okay trick or treat I'm
who's tricks whose treats
how are the narratives set who are the
players that have been coming through as
of late that you can continue to deal
with and feel good about and who are the
ones that maybe you got to be careful of
Oh a treat this chase Edmunds David
Johnson's out today continue to feel
confident in chase Edmunds maybe he felt
like a thorn in the side of David
Johnson orders he was but you have to
adjust your thinking this is a player
who the Cardinals believe can help them
with or without David Johnson we saw it
last week I'll continue to believe in
chase Edmunds even when David Johnson
comes back because they're not loaded at
wide receiver
this guy is facing nice wide open boxes
that always works out nicely keep
believing in chase Edmunds top 15 back
but he still should have some flex
appeal even when David Johnson is
healthy
he is a treat that will help your team
now a trick a trick a player I always
believed in but if you have Phillip
Rivers he is not your weekly starter
he's certainly not today he's got old
line issues Keenan Allen's playing it
less 100% they have not figured out
Austin Eckler in Melvin Gordon there's a
lot going wrong and not enough going
right here look in a good matchup I'll
play Phillip Rivers that's a no doubter
but there's too much up and down here
for rivers and the Chargers just one of
the first scenes I feel like I haven't
picked them to go to the AFC
Championship and they're proving that
right so far so Rivers and solid not
spectacular now we go to another treat
the hottest waiver wire pickup of the
week was Ty Johnson if chase Edmunds out
there was probably him but Ty Johnson
this week became a starting running back
in the NFL on a decent offense I can
tell you for a fact because the rule
status that carry on Johnson being on
the IR means he
cannot legally by the rule come back
until week 16 it's the fantasy
championship that means it's tied
Johnson's job barring injury or him
completely falling off a cliff he's a
solid enough back they believe in him we
saw him last week we'll get to McKissack
in a little bit but Ty Johnson just
became a potential RB 2 for the rest of
the season we'll go to the other side
and I'm not telling you that it's over
for this guy but I think you're getting
tricked by Todd Gurley because you're
not getting Todd Gurley of last year the
knee is a problem we know that it's
probably never gonna go away
you had the quad the thigh issue you
have Henderson there and if you look at
the numbers from Todd Gurley he's been
very touched in her life he is not
catching the ball at all that was a huge
part of his MVP caliber fantasy season
last year was catching the football he's
not doing that here's what Todd Gurley
is if you just cover the name and look
he's basically super-sized Derrick
Henry's in a better offense but he needs
the touchdowns to come through and he's
not catching the ball I'm not saying you
have to give up on him
but you might want to sell high on Todd
Gurley now back to a tree warm with
varying levels here
the Titans passing game is a treat why
they made a quarterback change to Ryan
Tannehill Ryan Tannehill is not going to
leave this team 12 wins I'm not gonna
say anything crazy like that but he's
willing to pull the trigger he made some
tougher throws last week he put it in
Windows where Mariota wouldn't even
think of doing it and he's got
playmakers around him Corey Davis they
drafted AJ Brown haddem Humphries is a
really good receiver Johnny Smith's
gonna come through today and he's got
they have the Buccaneers they have a
shot here there's life to this offense
will a receiver step up and be the guy
that remains to be seen we'll talk more
about Tannehill in a little bit but now
another trick
it's the bangles office Chad Ochocinco
is like 10 feet away from me man could
they use that guy what they could use a
better quarterback because hashtag bad
Andy is not an every other week thing
it's an every week thing winless team
total mess they're not gonna have fun
across the pond today you get questions
about Joe Mixon
I shouldn't be answering questions about
Joe Mixon but I have to because it's
that bad the lines bad he's not getting
enough touches it's Tyler Boyd I really
hope that AJ Green gets traded in the
next two days this is not an offense you
can trust that's your trick or treats
that's what we've done hopefully you've
learned a little bit more but now we go
back to the question so I can help you
juju or stills for Jay last Jew Jew if
you want to go juju in place say fine
you want to go for big upside I love
Kenny Stills and I like him a lot more
and you'll find out in a little bit why
Cara Winston a quarterback I do not like
Winston this feels like a meltdown game
against the Titans Derek Carr a deep
sleeper quarterback against the Houston
Texas and that comes from me coach
Gruden Dede Westbrook or Mike Williams
with Keenan Allen playing today I'll
play Westbrook against the New York Jets
moving on here from G Phil Alex Morgan
pick - Godwin mvs still Godwin who asked
about Chris God when it's week 8 he's
like the number one fantasy wide
receiver throw of Kenny Stills in there
Alex you got a good team break or Vance
I'll go Vance McDonald why when in doubt
we follow the Dolphins a smart fantasy
football politician told me that last
week Garoppolo a Rivers I'll take
Garofalo against the Panthers today do
not like rivers in his matchup now we go
to the video board from a championship
question yet an NBA champion has the
question this is Chris now I have a huge
fantasy question I begin hammered all
right I play daily fantasy I don't play
the league I don't play the hole I don't
do drafts we do a draft every well I
guess I do do drafts we do a draft every
weekend we played a daily stuff where
what do I need what's the how do I
figure out who's gonna do what you know
what I mean trying to figure out give me
the give me the secrets man give me this
and then don't play either give me the
secrets where do I find a secret
how do we help NBA champion Chris Bosh
make more money we do so in daily
fantasy Chris what I like to do in my
daily fantasy lineups as I go cheap
acquisitions I would normally stream in
redraft leagues so I go cheap at
quarterback I talked about car already
they talked about Jimmy Garoppolo will
get to another one coming up a little
bit and if I'm in the stream tight end I
like to go cheap there maybe it's Johnny
Smith maybe it's Josh Hill for you this
week maybe it's Eric breve Ebron it
could be any of those players and then
I'll go with a match if I really like it
running back a wide receiver and spend
up there I hope I help Chris Bosh and I
hope I helped you as well but now a
little more help for Chris Bosh and you
it's time for my sleepers
[Music]
Sleeper time two teams on buy plenty of
injuries as we've talked about maybe
it's your daily lineup a B it's your to
quarterback league maybe you just need a
little help because you're dealing with
plenty of injuries that's what we have
these year four and we start with Ryan
Tannehill yeah two weeks ago we wouldn't
have been even bringing up this guy's
name cuz he wasn't starting for the
Tennessee Titans but now he is had a
great game last week taking advantage of
the weapons he adds and he's got the
Buccaneers today one of the best
matchups you can have for a passing
offense he also can run he's sticking
the tongue out that always means a
quarterback likes to run if he sticks
his tongue out you could take that to
the bank I think we'll see plenty of
that today take a shot on Ryan Tannehill
now a running back a lot of talk about
his teammate on the waiver wire but take
a look at JD McKissack today
yeah Ty Johnson should be the guy for
the Detroit Lions but the matchup for JD
McKissack will just start with today
it's very good against the New York
Giants a bottom five defense against
fantasy running backs over the last
month you can catch some passes I think
there's something here in mckissick as a
solid flex option and it could be four
more than week eight now my favorite
sleeper of the weekend I don't even know
if people really sleeping on them but I
have high expectations for Kenny Stills
always like Kenny Stills never been in
the best situation even coming to
Houston at the beginning of the season
they had fuller and Kiki cootie and
DeAndre Hopkins
well Fuller's hurt now this guy stepped
up last week and went for a hundred
yards
I spent a bunch of money in my league to
go get Kenny Stills
he's got the Raiders today which could
be a top-15 performance um Kenny Stills
and somebody who can help you as long as
we'll fuller is out he's a real good
sleeper for this week check out that
sleepers article comes out every Friday
for the full list of sleepers but now
more of your questions specifically the
use
people hello YouTube nice to see you DJ
torque or James white for Evan Evan you
got to go charkh I like both guys you
got a pretty good team if you're putting
one of them on the bench next up here
Josh Allen or Drew Brees from Kosta
Kosta I'm gonna go with Josh Allen yes I
have that much confidence in him
against the Eagles today next up Josh
Allen or Matthew Stafford from David
very closely ranked I'll say Stafford is
a little bit safer against the Giants
but I still like Allen's upside more if
you're down big from Thursday night you
might go with Allen for the upside Ty
Johnson or Carlos I'd from Michael
Michael I'm gonna go ty Johnston against
the Giants it's a great matchup and I
think the game between Houston and
Oakland will be more about going to the
air so new or Alshon for crispy I'm
gonna play al Sun I don't have a lot of
confidence in either guy it is 2news
first game with the Patriots let's go
with Al Sean hope for a touchdown
Curtis Samuel gets the Niners were Jaron
brown for Isaiah Isaiah I still got to
go Samuel air I don't like either guy
very much right plenty of questions from
YouTube plenty more questions to go but
I'm live in Vegas and people are out
here and they need help so we help them
to because they got up this morning and
they came out to watch welcome in here
come on over what's your name seasoned
bowling hello it's Tuesday what is your
question
well now that Josh Gordon's out what's
gonna happen receivers going forward
well it's all about Julia Hellman as we
know I think Mohamed Sanu could get
going could be a gadget player I'm
banking on him to throw a touchdown but
maybe we see Jacoby Myers and the other
younger players step up as well but
they're gonna be just fine because they
got 12 back there absolutely all right
there you go a Patriots fan has the
confidence and you should as well
there is the piano music it's time for a
matte moment
[Music]
week seven completely encapsulated in
that video my hip is destroyed I was
able to come through I am active today
but that's what last week was right
injuries random guys scoring touchdowns
who is amoureux for the Raiders he
scored a touchdown all these random
backup running backs and third string
tight end scoring touchdowns driving us
absolutely nuts
Patrick mahomes got hurt last week we
don't even have Christian McCaffrey
available carry out Johnson got hurt
David Johnson played a carry here's what
I'm hoping we could just shake off week
7 and I'm begging you I know it probably
didn't go well for you last week
but let it go it was one week you can
overcome that you still went to the
waiver wire this week you went to go get
ty Johnson or chase Edmunds or Kenny
Stills you're still trying to make those
big trades the NFL trade deadline is two
days away keep making those moves shake
off last week shake off the injuries
play through it be tough let it go it
was just one week they're gonna be okay
let's hope everything bad was confined
to week seven
that's my hope for you and that was
today's matte moment speaking of
injuries go back to the board we go we
have updates for you on our ins and outs
for our early game action Jack Boyles in
maybe had dropsy bran down just a little
bit don't feel great about the oil
anyway e bronze in the 1415 range
updating OJ Howard you don't have to
worry about even thinking about playing
him today he is out I don't like braids
against the Tennessee Titans speaking of
the Titans Delaney Walker's out Johnny
Smith is a deep sleep or at tight end
got a top ten potential week there for
him David Josh is out not the worst
thing in the world let him rest chase
Edmunds top 15 back Christian Kirk is
back wide receiver three at best against
the New Orleans Saints speaking of the
Saints drew Brees is back today gives
you confidence with cook-out and Alvin
Kamara out to take a look at Josh Hill
should be a very busy day for Michael
Thomas as well but Josh Hill good deep
sleeper and Dini Westbrook and sort of
question on ready he's in against the
Jets
playing in a very nice wide receiver
three level with wide receiver to upside
turned and still out by the leg keep
stashing them second page here for the
early games Starling separate is out
today again concussion unfortunately I
still like the Golden Tate a lot Ingram
and Berkeley of course Ian Allen's in
he's gonna play was a game-time decision
I will say this
he's not in the top ten but he could
still be a top 15 top 20 guy hopefully
it gets through the game doesn't get
banged up too much and that Ryan is out
it's a one win Falcon team why would
they mess with it I still play Julio
with confidence maybe gives you reason
to sit Ridley but you're still playing
Austin Hooper as well now late game
inactive some things we do know we'll
tell you about that Jacobs expected to
play Tyrell Williams expect it to play
moving gonna flex just to give yourself
a little option just in case Julian
Edelman he'll be fine
Bella checks board he's just writing
names down and in fact the Holmes is out
not a bad thing let him sit down let him
get a little bit healthier sounds like
you'd be back soon I don't think you're
allowed to Vontae Adams tonight either
all right all that was done very quickly
to get you ready and me ready for the
speed round
[Music]
didn't expect to see this coming out
right look at this hair it's me Nicole
we're like children to the corner
something like that I'm at home where do
I put this I'm gonna put it on the wrist
today speed round time thank you to the
coach he's trying some things Oh
Tevin Coleman or chase Evans your
standard scoring just said it David
Johnson's out I'm gonna continue to play
chase Evans and feel pretty good about
that no one's touching them off we're
touches shady breed at Jacobs Murray
swimming take up then I'll play him and
Murray with Alvin Kamara out for Aaron
next one up here breeze argh off I love
golf across the pond against a very
beatable awful Bengal team so fire up
Jared Goff today he could take advantage
of a good matchup which waiver wire
tight end should I start Goddard Josh
Hill Ebron or Vance McDonald I like
Ebron I think Josh Hills are upside play
but I do like Ebron today so give them a
shot is Julio a bench rep he's not a
bench you never been to Leo coaching and
we're gonna put this coach's mustache on
you now you go super fascinating okay
never been truly up come on we know
that's next camara doesn't start he
doesn't there goes the mustache do i
flex Amendola mckissick Collier Beasley
goes McKissick ah go back to that he's a
deep sleeper my money is where my mouth
is and that mustache it on the ground
latavius Murray ty Johnson or Eckler I
kind of like going Murray because it's
against the Cardinals and we do not have
alvin kamara today build defense or the
Chargers defense I'll take the Chargers
defense one thing they might have going
for them right now mad sabor de Toro
Seto Javon Barker that's the rough one
we're gonna play the toys were set today
now I got to a bunch of questions but if
you have plenty more I'll be in the app
for the next 30 minutes taking those
questions don't forget big board on
Wednesday sleeper article on Fridays the
mailbag on Friday it's all there for you
and I'm here for you every single Sunday
morning 11:30 Eastern 8:30 Pacific here
at seems we do sports will come out out
watch or watch this on all bleacher
report platform
I'm Matt Tam good luck in week 8 happy
Halloween that's been your fan if you
fire drill
you